did you have any fomo not filming season
seven
um no
well your friends still love you a lot
and i actually have some messages from
them to show you
hey cam hi cam hey what's up you're so
sweet
cameron you wrote a book
i know it's so weird it's so weird to
see it and actually
hold it is it weird to see someone else
holding it and knowing
someone else read it yes well you
had did you read it you can be honest
yes i read it and i laughed i cried
i winced oh my god okay because the only
person i have to go by so far
is my mother she has read it and of
course she's my mom so
she loved it but no i read it in one
sitting like and it's the easiest read
and it i don't think it was necessarily
written for someone like me
but i walked away with learnings um
good you lay out so
much in this book so from the real world
to baby yeah it's all over the place
and it's things that people don't like
talking about post-crime depression
hating breastfeeding mom guilt not
wanting more kids
was there anything that you went maybe i
shouldn't put this in the book
i do kind of regret talking about the
uncontrollable farting
after i had i do that was a bit much to
share but
it's real life so i i wanted to not hold
back
that was my favorite part of the book
the part that made me cry laugh so
i'm glad you kept today the best of us
the uh the machine gun flatulence i
think you describe it
um but what was the hardest part of
putting everything
on paper um you know it really was not
hard for me it was easy um i found it
very cathartic
to talk about my experience um i wanted
to be open and honest for other women
and
the biggest point that i tried to get
across i felt like when i was pregnant i
read
all these books that tried to tell you
what to do or
do it this way don't do it this way and
what i hope comes across to women is you
ultimately have to go with your gut
and your baby will be like like your
baby will be
unlike any other baby and you are unlike
any other woman so
that's what you have to go by well i
think mission accomplished
because you do you share every piece of
learnings you've had with the caveat of
this worked for me it may not work
for everybody because nowadays yeah you
have to preface it with
this was my experience doesn't mean it's
going to be yours absolutely
the whole book kind of reads like a love
letter to palmer
in a way is it kind of a book for her to
read one day and see what her mom went
through
you know i never thought about it that
way but
that would be great um the whole time i
was writing it i did keep in the back of
my mind
i want this to be something that she's
proud of and not embarrassed of or
ashamed of because books are around
forever kind of like reality television
[Applause]
[Music]
well the book kicks off with your
experience on
the real world i actually went back into
the vault and pulled up
your kind of casting tape and i want to
play it back for you now so you can see
19 year old cameron cameron i'm 19 years
old from anderson south carolina
i always told myself i will not live in
the south as soon as i graduate high
school i am getting the hell out of here
and now that that time has come i
honestly don't think i could
that's it just 15 seconds and here i am
still here uh but what would you tell 19
year old cameron anything or would you
let her live
in the naive oblivion of being 19. i
would let her live
in the naive oblivion because i have
learned so many lessons in my life
um i would have i would have gone back
and done it all the exact same
and maybe you would give her a copy of
one day you'll thank me maybe that's
what
maybe i would yeah and my southern
accent was a lot stronger back then
for sure i do not like people from up
north
yankees as we so-called southerners call
them the real world chapter
kind of kicks off the book and then
southern charm helps wrap up the book
is that funny why was why did you put
southern charm at the end because i
i think fans might be inclined to skip
ahead and read that one first and then
go back
um well i mean you know you can't not
include southern charm
it was been a big part of my life i was
on the show for um
six seasons i remember when whitney
convinced me to do it thinking this will
probably only last
one maybe two seasons and here it is
still on the show's been a great success
so i don't regret it for an instant i
would go back and do it all over again
did you have any fomo not filming season
seven
um no not
um it's you know it just got to be a
point in my life where i felt like it
just
it didn't it really didn't serve me
anymore i felt like i didn't quite fit
in anymore
and again i just ultimately had to go
with my gut and say i think now is the
time
um to bow out instead of drag this on
and
and i i felt myself um not being
as authentic as i was part of me started
to feel hypocritical you know these
people are showing their children their
their significant others and
um when you're on when you're on reality
television especially bravo these days
you know
that's expected of you um and um i
didn't want to do it so
try as you might though your name was
still brought up this season
yes of course uh
i have not do you think i should yeah i
think
something's stressing her out and i
think it's just because she hasn't like
let her hair down in a little while i
know but i don't want to give her a
guilt trip
it made it seem like you were meant to
come back and maybe made the decision at
the last minute was it a last-minute
decision
yeah no i i gave my decision to
um to bravo before filming even started
um that is the misconception i've got
the email receipts to prove it if
anybody wants to challenge me on that
um i did give my decision beforehand
you say a few times in the book that uh
reality tv has become
more manufactured or too manufactured
from your first experience
what do you mean by that was there any
example you can think of of like this
kind of
turned me off yeah well you know back
when i did react when i did the real
world that was kind of
in in the heyday of it and um at that
point it was hands off
uh producers did not talk to you in fact
if you talk to a cameraman the cameraman
would probably end up getting fired
nowadays it's it's different you know
there is
interference with production so it's
heightened reality i like to call it
heightened reality it's not a 100
real unfortunately anymore how do you
feel about that your name was brought up
in this
terrible rumor i heard some [ __ ]
sorry i heard that jason was having an
affair
if it's madison then it's not madison
can you believe that oh no i can
actually like tell you that's absurd
you know again it is what it is um it's
a part
of unfortunately it's a part of the
machine that is reality television um
i signed up for it so i can't really say
oh woe is me
um it's it's not that shocking to me
this is this is
it's part of being on reality television
it gets views it gets talked about
um and it is what it is
well your friends did a good job of
squashing it and taking care of you
and i know they still love you a lot and
i actually have some messages from them
to show you
okay hi cam i just wanted to send a
quick message to say congratulations
i am so proud of you and excited for you
with this
book coming out and like selfishly i can
say i have an author friend
amazing um anyway congrats baby hey
what's up cam
i just wanted to pop in from an airplane
over in oax
and uh we'll shoot up this congrats i
always told you
you'll thank me later but i love
spending the last
nine years with you so proud to see
where you've come and we're going and uh
yeah i can't wait to read it
so i'm sure it'll be a little more
entertaining than chefs
hey cam congratulations on your book
i am doing what you did not long ago in
the studio
recording the audiobook it's uh it's
been a lot of fun
reading it but uh yeah kind of a pain in
the ass to get all the words correct
but i hope to see you soon and uh really
happy for you
and we're gonna do a book tour remember
it'll be a lot of fun
cheers god help can you imagine
i think people would love to see it um
but what does it mean to you to see
those messages from them they're so
sweet and
and literally i mean i i talked to i was
on the phone with shep yesterday i
still have not met taylor i'm dying to
meet her i feel like i know her but i
still have not met her so he's like i'm
very covered careful i am a germaphobe
so i
i really don't leave my house um still
so i keep telling i'm like i'll see you
once i get the vaccine once i get the
vaccine i will see all of you
you said you would go back and do
southern charm all over again but do you
ever
think you might return to the show in
the future if circumstances changed
um no you know i never say never but
at this point i i think i think that
chapter of my life is closed i've been
on reality television since i was 19
years old so
i don't know we gotta we gotta think of
something else for me
i feel like you're kind of living in the
moment these days and not thinking too
hard about
what the future holds that's kind of the
way i lived my whole life
yes when do you think um palmer will get
to watch the real world or southern
charm
oh my gosh um hmm i would say
first of all it it's it fascinated when
i did bravocon
there were like eight-year-olds coming
up saying oh my god we let him like
your parents allow you to watch this at
eight years old so it
i would say at least 16 15 16. has jason
read the book or parts of the book
jason has not read the book he has not
read the book i put it on his bedside
table i ask him every day
have you read the book have you read the
book yet he comes home from work and
he's so exhausted he just
no he has not read the book okay well
jason we got some homework to do i know
you do open up
a lot about your relationship for the
first time in the book
did you have any trepidation about that
because you had kept it so private for
so long
no i think um part of the reason that i
kept it off reality tv
is uh my relationship with jason is very
precious to me
and i know how the reality television
machine works
and um it's very rare that you see
a marriage on reality tv spun in a good
light
nobody wants to watch a happy go lucky
easy easy marriage so
i that was part of my decision in in
keeping
it off and it was also part of my
decision in in leaving the show because
i started to feel
a little bit hypocritical in a way that
you know i was kind of the voice of
reason
and commenting on everybody else's
relationship but i
i didn't want to show mine so that that
weighed in my decision
yeah i didn't realize that you had been
with jason for a full
like two years before southern charm
started filming
i mean that might be news to some fans
how do you think
they will feel like you kept a secret
from them
um i don't know maybe i could see how i
would feel that way if i was watching
um jason just at that point he supported
me doing the show he just
he didn't want to he didn't want to be
on it and i can respect that
well what's next for you and do you have
an idea for another book
are you what are you thinking about no
um i've never really had a plan with my
life
i i would say if this book does well i
would like to do a children's book um
that's kind of always been a dream of
mine
as well and i'd like to somehow
incorporate little elvis
who's been such a part of our family so
maybe a children's book about elvis
i love that yeah we just lost elvis
which i know everyone was so sad about
but he that dog lived a life he lived a
life
he totally lived a great life so he was
almost 18 years old are there plans for
once an appropriate morning period has
passed are there plans for another dog
or why don't you just wait till another
dog enters your life
by accident uh we're gonna take a little
break for a while for sure
little break well it's great catching up
with you congrats on the book i'm
putting out new york times bestseller
into the universe oh my god let's hope
you